cam's way ahead of where he was last
year
at this time there's no question about
that i mean it's
you know as you would expect he
you know has a good year of experience
under his belt and is able to start the
process
at the beginning
and not being a catch-up mode like he
was last year um
i mean he was really just starting at
this point uh last season but
you know he's he's well ahead of that
just from the year of experience and
from the
you know the succession of building
blocks that he's been able to
just stack up like all the players have
that you know have been here since the
start of the ota didn't make me feel any
type of way because he was the right
pick you know what i'm saying in my
opinion and
he was the best player available and
that's what the nfl draft is for um as
far as
you know having any any chip on the
shoulder like i mean
stating the obvious i don't need too
much to get myself going let alone you
know that happening and there's no
disrespect to mac there's no disrespect
to you know dealing in his decision i i
support it 110
because there you still have to do
what's right for the organization
what a difference in presentation
from cam newton to bill belichick
as belichick was talking it struck me he
looked like a guy who has the flu and
got himself together just enough to go
to the doctor's office to get checked
out that that was the vibe that he had
yeah yeah you're right it does look like
that you're right that's why he's the
all-time curmudgeon though i mean that
is why i mean who knows with bill no one
bill he might have sat up he might have
slept on the couch the night before even
from mini camps i mean he's that kind of
guy i mean it's just when it's time to
work in new england they're not looking
into the mirror to see how their hairs
come they just get after it and they
grind and that's who they are and that's
why they're that's why they're new
england
that that pec that picture though
suggests all sorts of unfortunate oh you
could have a lot of fun
yeah you know i mean definitely god all
right uh so how about a little fill in
the blank mini camp style the cam newton
versus mac jones competition will be
what chris
good for cam newton i think that's the
thing i'm going to look at at just from
that little you know fill in the blank i
think it's the best thing for cam newton
to have that guy that's right there that
he knows is the future is gonna be
you know
johnny type a quarterback and be on
every detail in the world and i think
that's gonna push cam newton to mentally
be all over things and of course you
know on the field physically be all over
them too so i think this really
ultimately even though it might not like
long term be the best for cam i think in
a lot of ways is going to be the best
for cam to make the most of himself for
2021.
i'm gonna say it's good for the patriots
it's the first time they've had anything
like this in years and it sets a tone
of competition throughout the
organization it's almost like the
seahawks mentality where it's compete at
every position except quarterback we
don't want competition there but when
you have a full-blown competition at
quarterback and you see that yes the
best are going to play
that that may make some of these other
guys step up and try a little bit harder
and develop and it and it helps lift the
whole thing
i saw some tweets yesterday from beat
writers who were at the mini camp
practice that it it's
it it was
becoming apparent that they were
accelerating mac jones development by
getting him
more reps yesterday so maybe they saw
something on monday in the rain that
they liked because he got some more
opportunities on
tuesday and and the thinking is it's
just a matter of time before he's the
guy right the question is does it happen
at some point this year
is it next year when is it but cam
newton is the short timer and mac jones
is the future yeah definitely there's no
doubt and and
you know the fact that we're hearing so
much about
mac jones
out of a place where you never really
hear anything and other than the one day
of interceptions when cam hurt his hand
i mean it's all been positive i think
you know speaks it speaks loudly to me
you just don't usually hear this kind of
chatter out of new england so he's
obviously impressing some people and
this is an organization that does not
want to play these type of quarterbacks
or young players and just throw them out
there to be like here's your first run
pick we got to throw them out there no
they make you earn it they're not going
to throw you out there until they know
you're not going to mess it up for the
rest of the football team and uh you
know that also speaks to mac jones and
and that's why it'll be hard for him to
get out there too i think just because
of that trust factor but that's why he
was drafted at 15 and that's why i would
have drafted him at number three because
he's nfl ready and he's going to be
ready to go when the time comes it just
is going to be better than cam newton i
i'm going to say no
one of the developments from yesterday
and look we react to the news that is in
front of us we're months away from games
that count so when there are practices
and things occur we pay attention to a
ton of iowa authoring throwing three
interceptions in torrential reigns
caught our attention so dolphins fans
should feel what about their team with
tua as the starting quarterback chris
i think a little i'm gonna say nervous
is the word i'm gonna use and i don't
mean that as in like
you know just nervous as far as what
you're gonna get out of the quarterback
you know position
we don't know you know again last year
it was basic and i know it wasn't the
greatest talent around him and all those
type of things but you know they really
had to micromanage him big time you know
it was that was that was their focal
point when he came in it's just you know
let's not make him look bad let's make
it as easy as possible let's not is
putting much on his plate oh wait we're
down that's too much on his plate bring
ryan fitzpatrick in how can you not feel
nervous you know now i get a lot of hate
from down there because you know i don't
rank him as the five best quarterbacks
in football already but you know yeah
there's question marks here and to add
to it why i would be nervous i'd go
what it's a damn good team it's it's a
good team they're here it's time they're
a playoff team and he's the question
mark so that's why i say nervous
well and you know we've talked a couple
of times about his admission from last
month that yeah he didn't know the
offense as well
as he should
our first reaction was
it's refreshing that he was candid and
then and then we had the delayed
reaction of wait a minute if this was
anybody else he would have gotten killed
for it and now i'm kind of at the point
where okay let's spin this forward
why
why did you not know it last year
because i need to be concerned if you're
going to know it this year are you going
to know the game plan are you going to
be comfortable with the audibles the
checks all the things you need to know
until we understand why he wasn't where
he needed to be last year from the
standpoint of understanding the offense
we can't have confidence he's going to
understand it know it this year can we
no i mean you're that's that's something
yeah i think that's why you know we can
add that to why we i said nervous you're
right we don't know
was it was it you know lack of
understanding and being able to apply it
on the football field or was it lack of
like just quite understanding what it
takes to be all in as the nfl starting
quarterback you know so yeah it could be
either one or something else but
that is i think part of the process of
what we're going to be evaluating with
chuba here is like yeah the play on the
field but the look of the offense isn't
it is it opened up has it opened up and
because if it is opened up then i think
we'll you and i will go well it seems
like they trust them a lot more they're
putting the ball like there's that
moment when you know right like like
with quarterbacks i can still remember
and we talked about this last year too
where hey josh allen went to the
playoffs in year two and it was pretty
good and 20 touchdowns and six
interceptions and those type of things
but you knew they were still
kind of even in that year they were
micromanaging them they weren't going to
let him be crazy you know they they
tried to play football a certain way you
remember last year i think it was week
two they went down or maybe week three
the miami dolphins game and it kind of
started going back and forth and you
went ooh what's buffalo gonna do they
might be careful with josh allen here
they only have a four point lead they're
not going to just let him sling it
around and they just let him keep
throwing it and throwing bombs and
that's when i was like whoa
buffalo's at a different point with josh
allen it's official it's not about
managing them anymore they've basically
said no forget managing it you manage us
here's the ball win the game for us and
those are the kind of clues i'll be
looking for for fertua
on that same point from yesterday's news
the three interceptions in the
torrential rains throwing interceptions
at practice in the rain when the coaches
tell you to be aggressive that was to
his explanation is what a dicey
situation
you know it's a fine line of aggressive
and stupidity of trying to make a throw
when it's a torrential downpour so yeah
you'd like to be aggressive but not
aggressive to the point where man the
ball is slippery as hell it's raining
hard as hell it's windy i think i could
fit you know this 30-yard throw in the
hole between the safety and the corner
in there that's aggressively stupid
they're not gonna get that done but what
they're saying too is also like hey if
there's a 10 yard curl open and he's
wide open throw the freaking ball yeah
it's wet or whatever else but don't just
look for the check down and be like oh
it's wet let me look for the running
back you know that that's what we're
looking for there
tua said
now's the time to make mistakes and i
keep thinking back to 2015 the
breathless reporting of marcus mariota
hadn't thrown an interception hasn't
thrown an interception hasn't thrown an
interception aaron rodgers that same
training camp said i want to throw
interceptions because this is how we
shape
the zone the target i know who i can
trust i know what the window is i learn
it through training camp now is the time
to make the mistakes and see what the
limits of your abilities are so you can
you can find the sweet spot when it's
time to make those throws in the games
that count
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports